a Michigan office manager risks his
career to expose a doctor who gave
chemotherapy to patients who did not
have cancer doctor Farid FATA gave
unnecessary treatments to more than 500
patients at a Detroit Area Cancer Center
in tonight's episode of the CBS News
series whistleblower host Alex Ferrer
talks to the former office manager who
stepped forward to expose a man
responsible for this I couldn't believe
what was in front of me I couldn't
believe what I was seeing
George kurachi took a new job in 2011 I
was an office manager for an oncology
practice doctor Farid FATA had a rapidly
expanding practice in suburban Detroit
but within two years one of the other
oncologists and two nurse practitioners
announced they were leaving karachi
confronted that other oncologists are
you leaving and he said yes and I said
can I ask you why what the doctor told
George Karachi about dr. FATA was a
bombshell
patients were given chemotherapy and
other treatments when they didn't have
cancer Roberts ovary was referred to dr.
FATA by his back surgery I heard he was
one of the best there is
I am doctor Farid FATA with Michigan
hematology oncology dr. Farah did a bone
marrow biopsy two weeks later he turn
around said you got multiple myeloma so
blood cancer a bone destroying disease
he began monthly chemotherapy infusions
I'd become weak sick to my stomach
tired all the time I couldn't walk
anymore the chemotherapy eventually
destroyed all my teeth so bere went to
see a different oncologist he was shaken
by what he heard faces I see both
biopsies is nothing says that you make
cancer anywhere in there I was shocked
it was worse than hearing that you have
cancer I was determined to have this
doctor stopped harming Pete
his head spinning Jorge contacted an
attorney he knew who handled
whistleblower cases Jorge believed he
might have a strong one we've heard a
lot of strange stories about fraud but
that one was was beyond fraud it was
cruel it was criminal
it was risking people with poison David
Herren wasted no time he called the
Department of Justice without a doubt
this is the fastest and most intense
lawsuit I've ever handled in this area
Jorge Karachi was willing to put
everything on the line my job was at
stake my livelihood even my own personal
safety I wasn't looking at the patient's
any mores being treated I looked at it
as a burning building with people inside
I had to make it stop and I had to make
it stop quickly boy Thank You mr.
Karachi Alex Ferreira joins us now at
the table good morning to you al good
morning Gail how you kind of did I'm
pretty good what kind of despicable
behavior how could he get away with this
for so long without anybody knowing well
you know and private practice doctors
have little to no oversight there's
nobody there to really check what
they're doing and he would provide the
chemotherapy in his office so there was
even less likelihood of getting caught
on the rare occasion that he did go to a
hospital it was before 6 a.m. or after
11 p.m. so that nobody would be
questioning his medical decisions it was
the perfect fraud and as a result over a
very short period of time he subjected
over 550 patients to unnecessary
treatment why there's big money why
greed just total unadulterated greed
using their body their lives to pocket a
few thousand dollars in every treatment
it's it's incredible and here that
attorney you've categorized it as you
know he's seen a lot of bad schemes out
there this is the lowest of the low
well I've been a police officer I've
been an attorney I've been a judge I've
seen just about everything and this
still blows my mind that he would do it
himself in his office poison him and
then watch it happen yes despicable
really applies it's an amazing episode
thank you Alex rare but you only do a
minute careful that's all good
go whistle blower airs tonight at 8:00
p.m. 7:00 Central right here on CBS